♪ ♪
>> Greg: HAPPY THURSDAY,
EVERYBODY.
YEAH!
ALMOST FRIDAY.
IT'S A FUN DAY TOO.
IT'S ONE OF THOSE SPECIAL NIGHTS
FOR US WHEN WE LET YOU, THE
AUDIENCE, CHOOSE THE MONOLOGUE
TOPIC.
NOBODY ELSE DOES THIS.
IT'S A SEGMENT THAT WE CALL...
>> THE AUDIENCE DECIDES THE
STORY!
>> Greg: KIND OF REDUNDANT AT
THIS POINT.
I MEAN, I HAD ALREADY SAID THAT.
THE RULES ARE THIS, I TELL YOU
TO TOPICS AND THE STRONGER CLAP
DETERMINES WHICH STORY WE ARE
GOING TO CHOOSE.
FYI, THIS IS EXACTLY HOWY
PARENTS DETERMINED WHO GOT FED
AT DINNER.
HOLD YOUR CLAPPING UNTIL I TELL
YOU BOTH TOPICS.
THE FIRST STORY, THE INFLATION
RATE, AS YOU KNOW, IS A CRITICAL
MEASUREMENT ECONOMIES HEALTH.
THEREFORE UNDERSTANDING HOW IT
CORRELATES TO OTHER ECONOM
MEASURES IN A STABLE ECONOMY
MIGHT HELP US COMPREHEND THESE
INFLATIONARY CYCLES.
ALL RIGHT.
THE SECOND TOPIC, WHAT THE HELL
IS UP WITH THE TRANS-SCHOOL SHOP
TEACHER IN CANADA WITH GIANT
INFLATABLE BOOBS?
YOU GUYS CAN'T FOLLOW THE RULES.
WERE GOING TO HAVE TO DO IT ALL
OVER AGAIN.
ALL RIGHT, LET'S COMPARE.
STORY ONE ON INFLATION.
YOU DON'T COUNT, TYRUS.
STORY TWO, ALSO ON INFLATION.
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
ALL RIGHT.
SETTLE DOWN, YOU PERVERTS.
THE AUDIENCE DECIDES.
GIANT BREASTS WINS BY A NIPPLE.
I AGREE THE CONTEST WAS A BUST.
IT'S TIME FOR...
>> IF IT HAPPENS THERE, WE
REPORT DOWN HERE.
YOU'RE WATCHING GAZOOMBA GATE.
WEEK 13.
>> Greg: THIS STORY IS GETTING
BIGGER AND BOUNCE HERE AND LIKE
SPEEDS OLD REPORT CARDS, THERE'S
A LOT OF Ds.
BECAUSE OF THE NEIGHBORHOOD JUST
TUNED IN FOR THE FIRST TIME.
SHE WAS ONCE HE BEGAN
IDENTIFYING AS FEMALE LAST YEAR
AND STARTED WEARING MASSIVE
PROSTHETIC BREASTS TO CLASS.
THE SCHOOL BOARD STANDS BEHIND
THE TEACHER.
NO OTHER CHOICE.
THE UNLIKELY EVENT OF A WATER
EMERGENCY LANDING, YOUR SHOP
TEACHER CAN BE USED AS A
FLOTATION DEVICE.
IT THE ONLY SHOW THAT KEEPS
DILIGENT TABS ON THE ONTARIO
GENDER TEACHER.
IS IT A PRANK THAT'S GOTTEN WAY
OUT OF HAND?
HOW ABOUT A LITTLE COMMON SENSE.
WOMEN DON'T EVEN LOOK LIKE THAT
IN MY DREAMS.
THE SHOP TEACHER WAS RECENTLY
PICTURED IN ALL HER IMMENSE
BOOBERY SKYDIVING.
WHAT HAPPENED SINCE THEN?
PARENTS OF THE OAKVILLE
TRAFALGAR HIGH SCHOOL STUDENTS
HAVE HIRED A LAWYER TO BEGIN
LEGAL PROCEEDINGS AGAINST THE
DISTRICT SCHOOL BOARD.
THEY ARE FRUSTRATED WITH THE
BOARD'S LACK OF TRANSPARENCY,
UNLIKE THE TEACHERS SPUTTER.
AND THEY ARE FEARFUL OF THE
GROWING THREATS OF VIOLENCE
AGAINST THE SCHOOL OVER THE
OVERT ATTIRE OF A TRANSGENDER
TEACHER SO THEY TOOK ACTION.
STUDENTS FIRST, ONTARIO, THAT'S
THE GROUP, NUMBERING 100.
SAID PARENTS HAVE FOLLOWED
PROTOCOL INITIALLY.
TAKING THEIR CONCERNS TO SCHOOL
ADMINISTRATIONS, TO THEIR
TRUSTEES.
THE BOARD STANDS BY ITS OFFICIAL
STATEMENT IN RESPONSE TO THE
TEACHERS LARGE PROSTHETIC AND
BRALESS BREASTS.
"COMMITTED TO ESTABLISHING AND
MAINTAINING A CARING AND
WELCOMING LEARNING ENVIRONMENT
FOR ALL STUDENTS AND STAFF."
OH, YEAH, DID WE MENTION WE LOVE
GIANT [BLEEP]
I DON'T THINK THAT WAS IN THERE.
STUDENTS ARE ALSO BEING
THREATENED WITH SUSPENSION IF
THEY PHOTOGRAPH THE TEACHER.
THAT'S INTERESTING.
AND YET HERE WE ARE, THE ONLY
SHOW COVERING THIS SURREAL,
THOUGHT-PROVOKING STORY.
WHY?
BECAUSE I'M OBSESSED?
NO.
MAYBE I JUST NEED TO GET THIS
OFF MY CHEST.
YOU SEE, A PARENT AT THIS SCHOOL
IS IN A NO-WIN SITUATION.
IT'S LIKE A MEETING WHERE THE
ONLY TWO EMPTY SEATS ARE ON
EITHER SIDE OF BRIAN KILMEADE.
LOSE-LOSE.
YOU CAN JUST SEE HIM SITTING
THERE.
THE TRANS-TEACHER IS EITHER
TROLLING THE SCHOOL OR DEMANDING
PROTECTION FOR EIGHTH FETISH
MASQUERADING AS A NONBINARY
TRAIT BUT IF THAT COSTUME IS
WELCOMED, WHY NOT ANY BEHAVIOR?
WHAT STOPS A TEACHER FROM
PUTTING A GIANT PROSTHETIC PENIS
IN THEIR PANTS?
DON'T THINK I HAVEN'T THOUGHT OF
THAT.
YOU DON'T KNOW THIS BUT I TEACH
INTRO TO TWERKING AT THE LOCAL
JUNIOR COLLEGE.
YOU CAN TAKE YOUR PRIVATE FETISH
PUBLIC AS LONG AS YOU PORTRAY
YOURSELF AS THE TARGET OF HATE,
IT WORKS.
WHAT IF THE PRINCIPAL AS A
DOMINATRIX.
KIDS WHO HAVE TO TAKE THEIR
WHIPPING OR BE CALLED A BIGOT,
WHICH WILL MEAN MORE WHIPPING.
NOW, WHAT IF WE JUST IGNORE THIS
STORY?
WE ALLOW THE NONSCIENCE OF
GENDER ACTIVISM TO UNLEASH
PUBLIC FETISHES ON ALL OF US.
THE INMATES WILL BE RUNNING THE
ASYLUM AND IT WILL LOOK THAT WAY
WITH ALL THE BONDAGE.
I MEAN, WHAT IF YOU HAVE A
FETISH?
WHAT KEEPS YOU FROM SHARING IT
AT WORK?
TELLING GERALDO TO COVER UP THAT
THONG WOULD GET ME TO H.R..
WHAT ABOUT THE SHOP TEACHER?
YOU WOULD THINK THAT TABLE SAW
WOULD BE ENOUGH OF A DETERRENT.
ONE OF MY FETISH IS FLASHING?
IT'S NOT MUCH DIFFERENT THAN A
MAN SLAPPING ON GIANT BREASTS
WITH NIPPLES THE SIZE OF FROZEN
PIZZA.
WHY CAN'T I WALK THE HALLS AND
AN OPEN ROBE.
I WAS WANTED TO BE CHARLIE ROSE.
LET'S WELCOME TONIGHT'S GUESTS.
HE HAS FIVE DAUGHTERS AND HIGH
BLOOD PRESSURE, AMERICAN
CONSERVATIVE UNION CHAIRMAN
MATT SCHLAPP.
SHE'S GOT THE EYE OF THE TIGER
AND A JAR ON HER DESK.
COHOST OF "THE BOTTOM LINE"
STARTING JANUARY 23RD ON
FOX BUSINESS, DAGEN McDOWELL.
LIKE BATHROOM TOWELS, YOU'LL
ALWAYS FIND HER HUNG OVER IN THE
SHOWER.
FOX NEWS CONTRIBUTOR KAT TIMPF.
AND FINALLY, HE HAS NO CLUE WHAT
A LADDER IS.
MY MASSIVE SIDEKICK IN THE
N.W.A.'S WORLD HEAVYWEIGHT
CHAMPION, TYRUS.
MATT, I THINK THIS MIGHT BE THE
FIRST TIME YOU'RE ON THE SHOW
WHEN I HAVE COVERED THIS TOPIC,
IS THAT TRUE?
>> Matt: YES.
>> Greg: YOUR WIFE HAS BEEN ON
MANY TIMES.
SHE HAS TALKED ABOUT IT A NUMBER
OF TIMES AND YOU WOULDN'T
BELIEVE HER OPINIONS ON IT,
QUITE SHOCKING.
HOW DO YOU ASSESS OR GRADE MY
REPORTING SO FAR OR ANALYSIS ON
THIS TOPIC?
THIS IS NOT SHOWING UP ON ANY
SHOW AS FAR AS I KNOW ANYWHERE.
>> Matt: I HAVE ONE OF THOSE.
IT'S CALLED A BELLY.
AND ALL I CAN THINK OF IS WHAT
WOULD'VE HAPPENED IF DR. FAUCI
HAD BECOME A PLASTIC SURGEON?
I ALSO AM A LITTLE EMBARRASSED
BECAUSE MY PASTOR SAID HE LOVED
TO WATCH ME ON "GUTFELD!" AND
HERE WE ARE.
WE HAD TO START HERE.
>> Greg: DON'T YOU THINK THERE
IS A SLIPPERY SLOPE AND I'M NOT
TALKING ABOUT HER [BLEEP]
YOU KNOW WHAT I MEAN.
IF YOU CAN'T STAND UP FOR
SOMETHING IT IS OBVIOUSLY
FETISHISTIC, THAN ANYTHING CAN
GO.
>> Matt: WE HAVE UNLEASHED --
BUT WE HAVE MADE HEROES OF
PEOPLE WHO SEEM TO BE STRUGGLING
IN THEIR LIVES, AND IT SEEMS TO
BE FRONT AND CENTER IN OUR
CLASSROOMS.
I THINK A LOT OF AMERICANS FIND
IT RATHER REPUGNANT.
IT'S GOOD TO MOCK IT BUT AFTER
THE MOCKERY, WE'VE GOT TO MAKE
THIS STUFF STOP.
LIVE YOUR LIFE.
THAT'S FINE.
BUT DON'T POLLUTE THE MIND'S --
>> Greg: YOU CAN DRESS ANYWAY
YOU WANT BUT THERE ARE KIDS
THERE.
AND I'M GOING TO KEEP COVERING
THIS STORY UNTIL IT'S --
I WOULD JUST KEEP COVERING IT.
CONGRATULATIONS, DAGEN.
VERY GOOD.
DAGEN HAS GOT A NEW SHOW
PREMIERING ON FOX BUSINESS
CALLED "THE BOTTOM LINE."
IS THAT CORRECT?
>> Dagen: THANK YOU.
WITH SEAN DUFFY.
>> Greg: SEAN DUFFY.
WHO IS THAT?
I'M KIDDING.
WE ALL KNOW WHO SEAN DUFFY IS.
HE'S GOT LIKE 700 KIDS.
HE IS LIKE THAT EIGHT IS ENOUGH
GUY.
SO THE KIDS ARE THREATENED WITH
SUSPENSION IF THEY TAKE A
PICTURE OF THE TEACHER YET THE
TEACHER CAN BASICALLY --
IS LOOKING FOR ATTENTION.
DOES THAT MAKE SENSE?
>> Dagen: NO.
ALL THE KIDS IN THE SCHOOL AND
EVEN THE TEACHERS WHO HAVE TO BE
UPSET ABOUT THIS HAVE A WAY TO
FIGHT BACK.
EVERYBODY NEEDS TO START WEARING
SUPER TIGHT JEANS LIKE DWIGHT
YOCUM TIGHT AND THEY NEED TO
START WEARING GINOMOUS
PROSTHETIC SCROTUMS.
IT DOESN'T HAVE TO BE SOMETHING
THAT YOU BUY ON THE INTERNET.
>> Greg: HOMEMADE?
>> Dagen: FOLLOW-UP GIANT
SWEATSHIRT AND SHOVE IT IN YOUR
GENES.
LIKE YOU HAVE A BIG OLD POSSUM
IN YOUR PANTS.
OR A WOMBAT IN YOUR BRITCHES BUT
EVERYBODY NEEDS TO BE WALKING
AROUND LIKE THEY ARE VERY
UNCOMFORTABLE.
>> Greg: WE CAN'T SHOW IT.
>> Dagen: EVERYBODY AND IN THE
ENTIRE SCHOOL.
IT WILL DESCEND INTO CHAOS.
KIDS WILL BE ABLE TO SIT FOR
MORE THAN A COUPLE MINUTES
BECAUSE THEY HAVE A GIANT
SCROTUM IN THEIR PANTS.
IT'S NOT A D.
IT'S A Z.
AGAIN, YOU WILL NEVER --
NOBODY WILL EVER BE ABLE TO PLAY
SPORTS.
YOU CAN'T, AGAIN, A BIG OLD
WOMBAT IN YOUR BRITCHES.
YOU CAN'T RUN TO FIRST BASE.
>> Greg: DAGEN, STOP.
THIS IS FROM HOLLYWOOD REPORTER.
FOXES DECIDED TO SHELVE THE
BOTTOM LINE.
IS BEING REPLACED WITH SOMETHING
CALLED "THE DUFFY ZONE."
>> Tyrus: NO ONE BATS WILL BE
HURT.
>> Greg: ANOTHER CAREER
DESTROYED BY ME.
I DON'T KNOW WHO TO GO TO NEXT.
I KNOW YOU BOTH DESPISE THIS
TOPIC.
>> Tyrus: TAKE IT AWAY, KAT.
>> Greg: DOES A LOT OF THINGS
I DON'T LIKE TO TALK ABOUT BUT
THIS IS A PHILOSOPHICAL
QUESTION.
RIGHT?
>> Kat: OKAY, WHEN YOU SAY
YOU'RE THE ONLY PERSON COVERING
THIS, YOU REALLY ARE THE ONLY
PERSON.
IT'S SO FASCINATING BECAUSE
THAT'S A PHILOSOPHICAL STUDY TO
ME.
THERE'S NOBODY THAT YOU'RE DOING
THIS VERSUS.
DON LEMON IS NOT OPENING HIS
MORNING SHOW, THE TRANS-PHOBIA
HAS GONE TOO FAR AT FOX NEWS AND
THEN SHOWING YOU TALKING ABOUT
THIS.
>> Greg: MAYBE HE SHOULD.
>> Kat: THERE ARE PEOPLE WHO
LIVE TO CALL OUT OTHER PEOPLE
FOR TRANSFER WILL BE ABOUT THIS,
THEY ARE LIKE, SILENT.
THEY HAVE NOTHING TO SAY.
NOBODY THINKS THIS IS NORMAL OR
COOL EXCEPT FOR APPARENTLY SOME
PEOPLE IN CANADA.
BUT CANADA IS NOT REAL.
SO HERE, NOBODY THINKS --
WE HAVE TO BLUR IT OUT.
>> Greg: THEY CAN'T BLURT OUT
AT SCHOOL.
THEY CAN HAVE A BIG --
CUT OUT THESE GIANT THINGS OF
SOMETHING BLURRY AND TAPE IT TO
THE NIPPLES.
THEY WALK AROUND, BIG GIANT
PLATES OF BLURRINESS, LIKE
SATELLITE DISHES, TYRUS.
>> Tyrus: I GOT THE GIST.
>> Greg: I HEARD YOU WENT
BOWLING LAST NIGHT.
HOW WAS IT?
>> Tyrus: IT WAS GREAT,
PHENOMENAL.
ANYTHING SPHERICAL, WE DON'T
WANT TO TALK ABOUT IT.
GOING TO END UP TALKING ABOUT
GENERATION Z OVER THERE.
I WAS READY TO TALK ABOUT
ECONOMICS.
SHAME ON ALL OF YOU.
UNFORTUNATELY, DAGEN, YOU'VE GOT
TO RUN LONGER, WIDER STRIDES, IT
HELPS.
MAY YOUR PANTS ALSO.
UNFORTUNATELY --
OH, I HAVE TO DRAW YOU A
PICTURE?
>> Greg: GET TO THE POINT.
>> Tyrus: UNFORTUNATELY
BECAUSE HE WOULD BE IDENTIFYING
AS A MAN, HE WOULD HAVE BEEN
SUSPENDED AS SOON AS YOU WALKED
IN THE DOOR.
WHERE ARE THE FEMINISTS ON THIS?
WHY IS IT THAT WHEN A MAN
DECIDES TO TRANSITION, TO GET
ATTENTION, THEY ALWAYS SUPER
SEXUALIFY WHAT IT MEANS TO BE A
WOMAN.
A SUPER SHORT SKIRT AND YOUR
NIPPLE, THAT'S NOT WHAT IT MEANS
TO BE A WOMAN.
EVERYONE IS TREATING THIS WITH
GLOVES.
I WEAR GLOVES.
THEY ARE NOT CALLING HER OUT ON
HER INAPPROPRIATENESS.
THE NEEDS OF THE FINISH IS MORE
IMPORTANT THAN THE NEEDS OF THE
CHILDREN IN THE COMMUNITY
BECAUSE OF THE VIRTUE SIGNALING.
WHEN THAT BY DEFINITION HAS
NOTHING TO DO WITH WOMANHOOD.
>> Greg: THERE YOU GO.
THAT'S WHY WE DO THESE STORIES,
KAT.
>> Kat: ALL RIGHT.
I AM IMAGINING IF YOU ARE A
PARENT AND YOUR KID'S NOT DOING
WELL IN SHOP CLASS AND YOU HAVE
TO GO TALK TO THIS TEACHER.